Why is South Korea's government making BTS
serve in the military?
I mean, yeah, it's required under South Korean
law that able-bodied men serve in the military
for two years.
But I mean, come on they’re BTS.
Famous people are always able to like pull
strings and like get out of stuff like this.
Right?
Not in this case.
The head of the military manpower department
said that it would be, quote, “desirable”
for them to serve in the name of fairness.
They’re trying to, like, lay a precedent
like, hey, everyone needs to serve, including
the rich and famous.
No one is exempt, which I guess that's fair.
Literally.
And yeah, we all hate the rich people who
get out of doing what we all have to do.
But in this case, it's different.
When polled, South Koreans say that they're
actually in favor of giving BTS an exemption.
They're like a national treasure.
They’ve brought so much prestige and attention
and revenue and tourism to this country.
But on the other hand, you've got to kind
of set a precedent here.
South Korea's military has been running low
on service members, mainly because of dropping
birth rates.
And by dropping birth rates, I mean the lowest
fertility rate on Earth.
In 2020, more people died than were born,
so their population actually went down.
Korea’s government is trying to lower the
physical and mental standards for people to
enlist, but perhaps this is a good idea.
Let BTS serve in the military and re-energize
people's view of military service.
This would certainly have an effect on the
many men who avoid conscription through some
questionable methods like dumping their citizenship.
So actually, I don't have my mind made up
on this.
This is a debate about fairness, about military
service, about the economy of South Korea.
What do you think?
Should BTS have to serve in the military?
Is it worth it?
Let me know.